a new study shows Americans are worried
but they're not worried primarily about
the coronavirus they're worried about
something that poses a far more imminent
risk to their lives and livelihoods as
the backlash against our national lock
downs begins to brew the response from
mayors and governors separates the
politician wheat from the politician
chaff then Joe Biden gets a major
endorsement now that there's no other
choice and the New York Times goes into
full damage control mode to cover for
grab happy Joe Biden all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I hate to say that I told you
so you know I hate it I would never do
it okay but you know sometimes it might
seem like I told you some I told you
this from the beginning I told you from
the very beginning of coronavirus that I
thought this was being overhyped that I
thought this was alarmism that I thought
people were becoming hysterical and they
shouldn't become hysterical because
there's no reason to and people mostly
on the left of me but some people also
who were on the right were furious with
me there were people who genuinely
believed that we were all going to die
from this thing on both sides of the
political aisle okay and that turned out
not to be true
these skeptics were right the alarmists
were wrong we're seeing so much evidence
of that all around the country at
virtually every level of our society we
will get to that the alarmists were
wrong really want to drive that home
because what you're going to be hearing
a lot in the next several weeks and
months and frankly for years because
this is a world historic event we've
never seen anything like this in the
global economy and the government's
response to it people are gonna try to
be justifying this for a long time
do not lose sight of the fact that the
alarmists were dead wrong now the
backlash to that is beginning the
backlash is beginning at the local level
state level the governmental level the
federal level is beginning all over the
place and just think about why that is
okay just just consider Florida and
California just consider these two
places right California was not hit hard
even though we were told by all of our
people in California the mayors the
governor we were told to California was
gonna be like New York it was gonna be
like Italy it was gonna be worse but the
reason that it wasn't the reason none of
their predictions came true is because
California closed down early okay that's
what they were saying at least close
down on March 19th
okay well Florida did not close down for
weeks
close down until two weeks later on
April 3rd and Florida has 198 fewer
deaths as of last night than California
so I guess maybe it wasn't the lockdown
because on top of that Florida didn't
even shut down completely Florida had
more exceptions than California did on
top of that Florida hosts Spring Break
where a bunch of teenagers show up and
definitely do not social distance
definitely a very good way to spread the
virus Florida I mean on a whole has
fewer deaths and even if you look at
deaths per million people Florida has
only eight more deaths per million
people than California also if you look
at the relative age of the population
Florida a lot older okay and yet they
look basically the same Florida's doing
pretty well if the lockdown is what
accounts for the relatively low death
rate then Florida should be getting
creamed right now and that's not what's
happening which backs up some studies
that we've seen elsewhere we just talked
about the one in Israel yesterday was
showing that the lockdowns really don't
do very much so in the face of all of
this the politicians who called for the
alarmism are trying to save face one way
they're doing this is cooking the book
so in New York right now we just saw
within the span of 24 hours 3,700 new
deaths added to the tally from
coronavirus 3,700 in one day well they
didn't all die in one day and actually
we'd have no evidence that they died of
coronavirus they just added 3,700 new
people to the tally who never tested
positive for coronavirus but who they
think maybe had coronavirus so this
brings the total tally up above 10,000
3,700 out of 10,000 that's a lot of
people okay that if you if you just
consider how many people they added to
the tally yesterday they increase the
tally by about 55 to 60% huge numbers
that boosted the nationwide total to
26,000 well okay I mean if it's
legitimate that's fine but where's the
evidence if we just counted every single
person who dies
every day is a coronavirus death that
7,500 people per day so we have to look
a little bit more closely here there's a
very big political incentive for the
alarmists to try to pretend that they
were not wrong for the alarmists to try
to pretend that they didn't just destroy
the economy for no reason
however the backlash is beginning we'll
get to that in a second first I got to
thank our friends over at Rock Auto you
know how much I love Rock Auto you know
if your car is having trouble Rock Auto
is an absolute godsend it is fabulous
rockauto.com has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil and even new carbon
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door I love it because I don't know
anything about Auto Parts right my car
breaks down I don't know how to do
anything so you go to the
brick-and-mortar brick-and-mortar they
ask you what your model is what your
year all this then they don't have the
part so they just go online they
probably go to Rock Auto then they
charge you twice as much doesn't make a
lot of sense rockauto.com always offers
the lowest price as possible they don't
change their prices all the time and
have all these gimmicks they just give
you the lowest price possible let's say
you happen to need Adelphi FG 1456 fuel
pump assembly for the 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey costs a three hundred fifty four
hundred dollars you know what a chain
store well that's the kind of thing you
get a rock order for two hundred and
seventeen bucks head on over right now
rockauto.com
right Knowles kayo wles and there how
did you hear about us box that way they
will know that we sent you there's still
the alarmists they're still trying to
say that everything they did was right
and really frankly it's going to get
even worse so CNN sent out this tweet
yesterday
say you know you got to take it with a
grain of salt CNN sent on a tweet quote
new study from Harvard researchers
published today in the journal Science
finds that prolonged or intermittent
social distancing may be necessary into
2022 yeah okay sure whatever reopen the
country oh yeah okay no you guys are
super smart definitely yeah we're gonna
have to Sochi
distance until 2075 yeah okay whatever
egghead opened the country up all right
you were wrong and I don't care that
you're trying to save face move on guys
okay
people are getting the picture here and
the protests are cropping up all over
the place as by the way I predicted on
this very show they would so there's a
Facebook group in Michigan that is now
trying to defy the governor's continued
draconian stay at home order
this is Michiganders against excessive
quarantine and they got a whole number
of new members they now are up to I
think 300,000 this is also happening in
North Carolina and Ohio so last week in
Ohio dozens of protesters showed up they
were carrying placards they were
carrying signs one of the signs said
quarantine worse than the virus and
there's a lot of hard evidence that
people consider this to be the case they
think that very likely the cure is worse
than the disease a little bit more on
that later but outside of Ohio and North
Carolina North Carolina is my favorite
in terms of the the reaction here
because it shows you just how shameless
the government has been in trying to
cover their political derrieres there's
a Facebook group called reopen North
Carolina started last Thursday already
has 21,000 members calling for protests
I mean why why in North Carolina would
this be the case well just consider a
few numbers ten point four million
people in North Carolina that's the
population of the state how many people
there have died from corona virus though
this whole time how long has it been
around now a month two months three
months 81 not 81 thousand not 80 100 not
810 81 people have died in a state of 10
and a half million how many people have
been hospitalized as you might say okay
the death rates low but the
hospitalization great 331 people have
been hospitalized in a state of 10 and a
half million that's why they shut down
the entire state I don't think so so how
are the states reacting there's a big
difference here at this it really
separates the politician wheat from the
politician chaff okay the dumb
politicians the way they're reacting to
this backlash
is there doubling down so I saw this in
Raleigh North Carolina the other day
there was a protest to reopen North
Carolina the local officials there
reacted by siccing the cops on them
so they sent the police to go break up
this perfectly peaceable perfectly
compliant protest some people were
outraged by this on Facebook so they go
if there were Twitter and so all over
social media they they tweeted at the
Raleigh PD they said why did you break
up this this protest and the Raleigh PD
in perfect obliviousness sent out a
tweet they said protesting is a
non-essential activity tell that to
Thomas Jefferson tell that to Sam Adams
how doncha protesting is a non-essential
activity take a little gander at the
Constitution Eric Garcetti mayor of Los
Angeles also reacting a very stupid way
he's doubling down rather than taking
the exit ramp because there's a
beautiful exit ramp right now available
to put to the alarmist politicians they
can still say and a lot of people will
believe them that all the draconian
measures they took were the whole reason
that the virus stopped it's not a lot of
evidence of that but whatever okay
that's his politics they could very
easily take that exit ramp but some dumb
politicians like my own mayor here in
Los Angeles are doubling down and so
when it when mayor Garcetti in LA says
two weeks ago that there is no world in
which two weeks from now LA is not like
New York than two weeks shows up were
nothing like New York things are doing
fine he extends the lockdown order he
Institute's fines for people who don't
wear face masks he's just so insistent I
was right I was right except he wasn't
it's clear that the most pressing
political liability right now for these
guys is not the virus okay they're still
living in the world of two weeks ago
where their most pressing political
liability is if they under react to the
virus that's not the new world war in
according to the public opinion polls
according to everything we're seeing the
bigger lie
ability is the economic shutdown this is
backed up by nate silver over to 538
according to the latest poll averages
538 is reporting that thirty eight point
eight percent of people of americans are
very worried that they someone in their
family or someone else they know will
become infected with corona virus then
on top of that another thirty six point
three percent say they are somewhat
worried that that will happen the
percentage who say that they are very
concerned has increased by about six
percent or so now a total of seventy
five point one percent say they are
somewhat worried about the virus now
we're seeing twenty three point six
percent say they are either not very
worried or not at all worried about the
virus but meanwhile at the same time
you're seeing a huge percentage of
people major surge in the virus or major
surge in the population saying that they
are very concerned about the economy and
these numbers have been shifting right
so it starts out people very very
concerned about the virus not worried
about the economy steadily those two
numbers have been shifting we're now at
the tipping point where all of a sudden
it's going to be all about the economy
as we are very clearly on the down slope
of virus infections all around the
country even in new york which was the
epicenter of the virus in the united
states the best evidence that the
backlash to this whole episode has begun
you don't have to take my word for it
the best evidence is that the a list
politicians the Varsity politicians the
creme de la creme of knowing how to work
the levers of political power the wheat
not the chaff they are now moving to
reopen across ideological lines
including very liberal people in very
liberal states they are now moving to
reopen because they can tell which way
the wind is blowing andrew Cuomo in New
York Gavin Newsom in California totally
different sides of the country major
states but Andy Cuomo had this to say
there is a coalition coming out to
reopen
Amerika those numbers say we can control
the spread feel good about that the
worst is over
it is not overwhelmed the health care
system we have controlled the spread and
there was there is confidence to be
taken in that and that's an
accomplishment and it was a heck of an
accomplishment those health care workers
for the rest of my life I will say
nothing but thank you to them and I was
not sure that we could keep the tide
from overwhelming our hospital capacity
and they did feel good about that and I
believe the worst is over if we continue
to be smart and I believe we can now
start on the path to normalcy and we can
have a plan where you start to see some
businesses reopening understand that
that understanding that delicate balance
this is a very different Andrew Cuomo
than we've seen over the past few weeks
a Cuomo's a very talented politician you
got to remember this guy's father was
governor of New York and he wasn't just
any governor he was an extraordinarily
successful popular liberal governor of
New York people wanted him to run for
president and Andy Cuomo was basically
running the guys campaign so this guy
has really good political instincts two
weeks ago you saw Andy Cuomo in the polo
t-shirt walking around the hospitals and
the Javits Center you know in the midst
of this crisis we got to shut everything
down
Andy Cuomo now you realize is mmm the
alarmism didn't quite come true even in
New York which was the worst in America
people now they don't want to see Andy
Cuomo in the polo shirt with whatever
was going on on his pectoral muscles I
don't know if you saw those nipple ring
rumors I'm not gonna spread them but it
looked a little weird they don't want to
see that for many reasons physical and
ideological now people want to see any
Cuomo in a suit talking about how we've
got to reopen America he's not the only
one doing that we will get to some more
evidence that the politicians see which
way the wind is blowing but first I got
to thank our friends over at We the
People pollster
you know it is so important if you've
got a handgun but no holster to keep in
mind you're just not doing gun ownership
right okay with with great power comes
great responsibility
take care of your gun it do it properly
holster that new handgun you know we the
people holsters starting in just 37
bucks 37 bucks we the people holsters
are custom designed to fit your firearm
perfectly they're made right here in the
USA very important these days made
overseas made in the USA their
proprietary clip design allows for you
to easily adjust both the can't and ride
of your holster so that it will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
now is the time to support American
companies I love these guys their
designs are excellent the quality is
perfect and they fit your gun absolutely
right to a micro micro micro millimeter
they're just so good go to we the people
holsters Khan / Knowles canna wles to
get yours every holster ships free comes
with a lifetime guarantee get an
additional 10 bucks off with the offer
code no let's wait a second so that
means it was 37 at 10 bucks off 27 bucks
for a great holster satisfaction
guaranteed if it's not a perfect fit
send it back for a total refund we the
people holsters dot-com / Knowles Cana
wles
we the people holsters comm / Knowles
so Andy Cuomo's saying we're gonna
reopen how is he gonna reopen he doesn't
tell anybody but he says we got a plan
it's much more important if you're a
politician to get out ahead of this
story and say that we've got a plan then
to actually formulate the plan they can
fill that in later Andy Cuomo was put
together obviously governor of New York
but then governor of New Jersey
Connecticut Pennsylvania Rhode Island
and Delaware put together this coalition
said they're gonna reopen the region's
economies and schools and other
important aspects of their state looks
like Massachusetts is joining in too so
that's the sort of Northeast contingent
they're all coming together real quick I
don't know maybe they're all reading the
same public opinion polls but they
realize this alarmism is not going to
help them when they're all up for
re-election so now they're moving to
reopen the economy it's not just the
Northeast the West Coast is doing it too
with our very own California governor
Newsom there's an old African proverb
that says if you want to go fast go
alone but if you want to go far go
together that's the spirit of
regionalism that's defined our approach
to addressing this pandemic that
regionalism extends throughout the state
of California and beyond we have had the
deep collaborative spirit advance now in
states large and small all across the
United States but none stronger than the
relationships we have formed in
Washington State in the state of Oregon
we just sent out a joint statement of a
shared vision for a process and protocol
a framework we refer to it for reopening
not just within our states but more
broadly as a region okay sounds like
he's doing a great job doesn't it can
anyone tell me what the plan to reopen
is no of course not Gavin Newsom doesn't
know what the plan to reopen is Gavin
Newsom is a cartoonishly empty suited
politician but empty suits tell us some
important facts about the state of
politics I think what really happened is
Gavin Newsom was sitting back watching
the news and he saw Andy Cuomo come out
there and say we've got a coalition to
reopen the states and so you have a new
some said odd drats call me a press
conference I'm not letting Andy Cuomo
have all the fun so he goes out there
and says yes we must reopen not close
we've got to get working not sitting we
write and he puts together this this
coalition as well he's just doing his
own version of what Cuomo's doing that's
what all the politicians have been doing
this whole time don't forget this was
part of my exasperation early on because
I have been well I'll just say it again
I told you so
I've been predicting since the very
beginning that this was an overreaction
and that the data would bear that out
but the data didn't matter to the
reaction right the government reaction
was actually wasn't a reaction it wasn't
reacting to the data that we were seeing
of hospitalizations of mortality it was
being proactive looking at the models
and the models are only as good as the
data that go in and the data were bunk
on the models so they were projecting
out they're going to be
thousand deaths 2,000 deaths two million
deaths four million deaths who knows
there was never any number too large for
them and all of the political incentives
were to one-up each other so I remember
it crystal clear when my own mayor here
in Los Angeles Eric Garcetti came out
and he said we're gonna have a lockdown
order in the state so you know you can't
go out unless you're an essential
business we're gonna lock down LA
because we're taking this seriously
gavin newsom
once again sitting back probably
watching TV he says I can't get
one-upped by that two-bit Mayor Eric
Garcetti call me a press conference
we're talking about within one or two
hours Gavin Newsom goes on TV we're
locking down this state yeah you thought
you could steal my limelight mayor
Garcetti no way we're gonna lock down
the state then the other mayors
governors all over the country we're
gonna lock down we're gonna double lock
down and we're gonna triple lock down
and they were all trying to one-up each
other on who could react most intensely
to the coronavirus very different
situation today now they're all trying
to one-up each other again because
that's all they ever do but they're
trying to one-up each other on who has
the quickest fastest most efficient plan
to reopen the economies this is a very
good thing it shows you that the
coronavirus phenomenon is officially
over how does it tell us this is what
we're hearing so often is the way that
will know when coronavirus is over is by
listening to the experts the way we'll
know when coronavirus is over is by
monitoring all the data no not really
I mean the data are showing us this -
they've showed us that the disease's it
accelerated very quickly then it kind of
plateaued for a little bit and now it's
on the decline whether that's because of
lockdown or not we don't know there's a
lot of evidence that that's the way the
disease spreads even in countries that
didn't lock down or only locked down
recently but it's actually not the data
and the science that are gonna show us
when this coronavirus epidemic is over
because the disease itself the virus
itself is only a small part of the
phenomenon of coronavirus the lion's
share of the phenomenon is the
government reaction
it's an the corona virus it's
self is not what's unprecedented we have
plagues we've had plagues for all of
human history we've had flus we've had
Ebola we've had bubonic plague we've had
all sorts of diseases that have spread
epidemics pandemics what makes this
unique what makes us a world historic
event
what makes this hotly-debated probably
for the next hundred years is the
reaction we've never ground the global
economy to a halt within a matter of
days because of a disease what tells us
that the coronavirus effectively is over
is the political response because the
coronavirus has been primarily a
political phenomenon we're talking
earlier about separating the wheat
politicians from the chaff politicians
successful politicians have one defining
characteristic they know which way the
wind blows that's that's what makes a
successful politician regardless of
their ideology regardless of their
policies regardless of what they want to
accomplish in office so really really
good ones know which way the wind blows
they can smell public opinion turning
and gavin newsom
and andrew cuomo these are successful
politicians Donald Trump very successful
politician you've seen all the really
talented ones shift their tone over the
past few days now this is about
reopening very good news now for guys
like you know maybe Newsome maybe some
of the alarmists Eric Garcetti certainly
for some of these local politicians
let's not let them forget that they were
dead wrong in the first place but we can
celebrate at least that the tide has
turned and I'd by the way I don't think
we should rub their faces in it I mean I
keep I keep mentioning you know that
what it was that uh-oh that I told you
so I keep mentioning this because I want
it to be clear for all of us to know
what this epidemic really was as we get
a barrage of misinformation over the
next few weeks as people start inflating
death numbers or change it I don't want
to even use that line
as people start changing the criteria by
which they they record deaths it's a
little more neutral way to put it
meaning they're gonna add thousands of
people to the death rolls even if they
were never diagnosed with coronavirus
they're gonna do a lot to cover their
political rear ends but look there are
plenty of people who've who've held
every extreme position on coronavirus
some people who said it's gonna kill us
all and then immediately after that said
actually it's it's totally fake and
there's nothing to a draw we got to
reopen okay I don't care whatever I
don't care their progression on this
issue as long as they end up in the
right place which seems like we are
right now as big political news a foot
not just on the coronavirus front but in
the presidential race we'll get to that
in a second first I gotta thank our
friends over it keeps you know very
important to take care of your hair even
during this pandemic okay because when
this pandemic is over we're all going to
emerge and we need to be looking very
good okay I'm not saying I'm some
hulking adonis of a man some Olympic
athlete or something one advantage I've
always had with the ladies got a full
head of hair
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 but with today's
advancements in science keeps offers
proven treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help keep the
hair you have at half the cost of your
local pharmacy prevention is the key
here all right keeps us up to 90 percent
effective at reducing and stopping
further hair loss you got to start using
it otherwise you're just wasting time
you're wasting your hair well thanks to
keeps you and visit a doctor online get
hair loss medication delivered straight
to your door they make it easy to
deliver it every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and Awkward doctor visits if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm slash Knowles
canna wles to receive your first month
of treatment for free that is K EEP
s.com slash Knowles now I want to thank
all of you in addition to all of our
sponsors we really appreciate the
sponsors we really appreciate you as
well
becoming a member and right now for you
we've got a special offer if you sign up
today to become a daily wire insider
plus or all access member typically you
get one leftist ears tumblr that's great
hey that's pretty good what more could
you ask
I'm glad you asked to leftist here's
tempers you thought one was good well
guess what
two is twice as good that's one for you
and that's one for Joe Biden's imaginary
friend give one to corn pop for
Christmas this year go to daily wire.com
slash subscribe you know you get all
this great stuff you get me you get the
and reclaim and show the ben shapiro
show the matt will show you get you get
so many shows and now you will get two
tumblers and on top of that you want me
to sweeten the deal you get 10% off with
promo code knowles we're just feeling
generous all right we're all in this
lockdown together so head on over daily
we're calm / subscribe coupon code
knowles get the rarest of all beverage
vessels x - we'll be right back
big political news a foot beyond
coronavirus Joe Biden presumptive
Democratic nominee for president he
finally gets the big endorsement he's
been waiting for his former boss Barack
Obama now you might have thought that
Barack Obama would have endorsed him
when it mattered at the beginning of
this presidential race nah
is Joe Barack Obama rather didn't think
that Joe could win you might have
thought that as the field narrowed he
was initially 27 candidates then let's
say a narrowed down to five or six you
thought maybe then Barack Obama will
weigh in nope he wasn't gonna do that
and was so awkward people kept asking
Joe Joe why isn't Barack endorsed you
and he said I didn't even want his
endorsement yeah okay buster then it
gets down to just him and Bernie then
now of course that's the time that
Barack Obama is gonna weigh in right
it's the politically safest time from to
weigh in now doesn't do that
then Bernie drops out Barack Obama still
doesn't weigh and he actually Bernie
Sanders endorses Joe Biden before Barack
Obama does but finally Barack came
around and offered Joe his tepid
endorsement I'm so proud to endorse Joe
Biden for President of the United States
choosing Joe to be my vice president was
one of the best decisions I ever made
and he became a close friend and I
believe Joe has all the qualities we
need in a president right now he's
someone whose own life has taught him
how to persevere how to bounce back when
you've been knocked down when Joe talks
with parents who've lost their jobs we
hear the son of a man who once knew the
pain of having to tell his children that
he'd lost his I know he'll surround
himself with good people experts
scientists military officials who
actually know how to run the government
and care about doing a good job running
the government and know how to work with
our allies and who will always put the
American people's interests above their
own
my favorite part of this endorsement
which has a lot of blather in it you
know the typical Obama Mean Girl jabs at
his political adversaries Obama's very
different than Trump right Trump just
goes right for the jugular and acts like
a man Barack Obama just gets these
little mean-girl jibes in there yeah
Jose actually he's gonna work with
people who actually care about America
not like I like Trump does those guys
those guys hate America he doesn't even
call out Trump directly doesn't call out
his adversaries directly because he's
too much of a little mean girl and he's
not a man so very different obviously if
you look at the Republican side of
things but okay that's whatever we
expect that from Barack Obama the
saddest part of this endorsement is the
big focus of it is he'll surround
himself with good people that's not an
essential part of a political
endorsement all the other stuff goes
along with every political endorsement
he'll exercise good judgment he'll work
with our allies he'll XY and Z but
Barack has to get in there that he'll
surround himself with good people
because Joe Biden is too old to be
President Joe Biden will be 82 by the
end of his first term in office if he
were elected so a lot of people are
thinking gosh is Joe gonna make it and
it's not even just the age thing as a
merely chronological factor he looks me
if he literally is 82 he looks like he's
a hundred and two he's forgetting where
he is he's forgetting his name he's
wandering off camera he's he doesn't
have it okay so it's gonna be very
important he surrounds himself with good
people because you don't know who's
gonna actually be running the country
what Donald Trump said is Joe Biden if
he gets elected somehow he's not gonna
run the country they're gonna put him in
a home he's gonna be watching TV and the
cabinet is gonna be running the country
so sadly for Joe Barack Obama seems to
be accepting Trump's premise that Joe
isn't gonna be really leading here that
it's gonna matter much more who he
surrounds himself with I also love the
rest of it he's gonna work with our
allies allies like Iran what's he gonna
do let Iran capture more of our sailors
and ship them pallets of cash like
the Obama administration did yeah he's
working with our allies great stuff
what's he gonna do piss off the United
Kingdom
piss off Israel go after it yeah okay
great okay Obama
I just forgot what a terrible president
that guy was in theory in the
hagiography and the revisionist history
that the left is made for Obama he's
this great guy everything was wonderful
and you remember the economy was
absolutely terrible he stole our health
insurance he he gave money at pallets of
cash to our enemies he let our enemies
take our sailors hostage without any
consequences other than giving them
money he had a bunch of scandals like
The Fast & Furious scandal he weaponized
the IRS to go after his political
opponents he was just awful
he was just a horrible president who now
has no legacy because Donald Trump took
it from him but the one thing I've
always marveled at with Barack Obama is
his ability to make absurd statements
with a perfectly straight face you know
he says Joe will actually put the
interests of the American people first
what by taking away their health
insurance saying they can keep their
doctor but then taking their doctors
away from them by admitting that it
would be illegal to give millions of
people amnesty and then just giving them
amnesty anyway unbelievable this guy but
then on this point of being able to make
absurd statements with a straight face
he outdid himself he said the real
reason we've gotta let to elect Joe is
because the Republicans have this
formidable terrible electoral machine
the Republicans they own the media the
Republicans have a major war chest
and so it's an uphill battle but the
Democrats may be able to pull it out
anyway so our country's future hangs on
this election and it won't be easy the
other side has a massive war chest the
other side has a propaganda network with
little regard for the truth massive war
chest and a propaganda network with
little regard for the truth eight out of
the ten richest people in the United
States are Democrats and major Democrat
funders the
the news network that Barack Obama is
referring to as being conservative as
Fox News Fox News has many liberals and
Democrats on the network
compare that to every other news network
which is explicitly and exclusively
left-wing CNN MSNBC forget obviously the
major TV networks NBC ABC CBS the New
York Times The Washington Post everybody
every single media outlet is
single-mindedly an explicitly left-wing
except for one which is slightly
conservative and that's it
they've got a propaganda network what
about all the other networks that are
all left-wing what about their war chest
okay virtually all of the billionaires
in America are left-wing now this reeks
a little bit of desperation and there
was no way for Obama to avoid this
unless he came out early for Joe Biden
it would look like he was just settling
for Joe Biden and that's what it looks
like the Democrats are doing and that's
a strong position for President Trump
Trump is ignoring the 2020 election more
or less he's plowing right ahead with
his agenda major decision came out
yesterday President Trump announced it
he is going to be cutting funding for
the World Health Organization a failed
mouthpiece for communist China he had
threatened cutting funding for a little
while now it's actually going into
effect today I'm instructing my
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted to assess the World Health
Organization's role and severely
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus everybody knows
what's going on there American taxpayers
provide between 400 million and 500
million dollars per year to the
w-h-o in contrast China contributes
roughly 40 million dollars a year and
even less as the organization's leading
sponsor the United States has a duty to
insist on full accountability one of the
most dangerous and costly decisions from
the WHL
was its disastrous decision to oppose
travel restrictions from China and other
nations they were very much opposed to
what we did fortunately I was not
convinced and suspended travel from
China saving untold numbers of lives
thousands and thousands of people would
have died this is very good news from
President Trump the w-h-o is worse than
useless just to give you an example
whe officials said on Monday that she
suspected that you could have human to
human transmission of the corona virus
as early as December 31st of last year
but the w-h-o officially was saying the
communist party line for weeks and weeks
after that saying that there was no
human to human transmission just one
example they've been parroting the
Chinese Communist line this whole time
also the w-h-o is just a big waste of
money to spend less than 15% of their
funding each year on the actual
priorities of world health the rest is
going to bureaucratic overhead and slush
funds it's just it's a waste of money
and it'd be one thing if it was our
waste of money
but it's not it's China's waste of money
they took over the organization and they
installed to the new head of it so just
pull the money good idea meanwhile over
in the mainstream media on back to the
2020 politics the New York Times as
representative of the mainstream media
are going to full damage control mode
because Joe Biden is the nominee and Joe
Biden has a sexual assault allegation
against him and the sexual assault
allegation against him is not all that
credible but it's much much much more
credible than the allegations against
Brett Kavanaugh that we saw two years
ago and the New York Times and everybody
else went crazy with those allegations
against Kavanaugh and now they're
basically silent on the allegations
against Joe Biden now they're publishing
beds about this they're the the
executive editor of the New York Times
actually just published an interview in
his own newspaper to try to defend his
indefensible decision not to cover the
accusations against Biden here's the
headline of this one The Times took 19
days to report in a queue
against Biden here's why Dean Baquet the
executive editor of The Times said the
article was published when there was
enough reporting to present to readers
for them to make their own judgment but
they didn't wait for there to be any
information on the baseless claims
against Cavanaugh before they ran them
two years ago why here is a very long
and pointless interview but here are a
couple of important moments so from the
interviewer I've been looking at the
Times coverage of justice bread and
Cavanaugh I want to focus primarily on
the Julie sweat Nick allegations she was
the one who was represented by Michael
avenatti and who suggested that
Cavanaugh had been involved in
frat-house rapes and then appeared to
walk back elements of her allegations
The Times wrote that story the same day
she made the allegation noting that
quote none of him is sweating exclaims
could be independently corroborated why
was Cavanaugh treated differently and
now listen to the logical gymnastics
this guy goes through Cavanaugh was
already in a public forum in a large way
this is Brett Kavanaugh the obscure
federal judge not Joe Biden the US
Senator and vice president of United
States who we've all known for 50 years
Cavanaugh was he was in a public forum
in a big way because he was a federal
judge nominated to the Supreme Court
unlike Joe Biden a three-time
presidential candidate Cavanaugh his
status as a Supreme Court justice was in
question because of a very serious
allegation the very serious allegation
with no evidence to back it up that's
the one the very serious allegation made
by a woman who had not made the
allegation before for decades and
decades very serious allegation that was
not even backed up by that accusers
friend who was allegedly at the party
where it happened very serious and when
I say in a public way I don't mean the
public way of Tara Reid's yeah look at
they're both in public ways right if you
ask the average person in America they
didn't know about the Tara Reid case
right because you didn't report on it
dude the only reason they knew about the
allegations against Kavanagh is because
you blew them up and made them into a
thing if you had reported on the Tara
Reid case then the American people would
have known about it against Joe Biden
he's pretending that he's not the New
York Times he's pretending that he's
some observer instead of the crafter of
news so I thought in that case if the
New York Times was going to introduce to
readers this story we needed to
introduce it with some reporting and
perspective that's a pleasant change of
pace Kavanaugh was a very different
situation right because you were just
trying to assassinate his political
career it was a live ongoing story that
had become the biggest political story
in the country right again because you
made it the biggest political story it
was just a different news judgment
moment yeah like now you're trying to
exercise some judgment and you're
actually just acting hypocritically and
defending it with judgment whereas the
previous time you didn't use any
judgment the interviewer then goes on
Christine Blasi Ford seemed to remember
it clearly and told the story very very
clearly pause no she didn't she changed
her story multiple times she couldn't
even remember how many people were at
the party she couldn't even remember
what happened at the party she couldn't
remember when the party took place or
where the party took place she changed
her story so many times she then said
that she had a door into a separate door
installed in her house because of the
PTSD from what happened at this party so
many years ago but there's no evidence
of that actually there were many other
explanations that she'd given for why
she had that particular door installed
to her house then she said she didn't
have any political points of view she
had posted her left-wing political
ideology all over the Internet her story
was bogus do you think that her
allegation on its face is more credible
than Tara Reid's and Dean baguettes as
well I don't mean to imply that in blah
blah blah BS there's another one in New
York Times this one comes out for
Michelle Goldberg the columnist what to
do with Tara Reid's allegation against
Joe Biden since Reid made her latest
accusation people on both the left and
the right have been demanding with a mix
of genuine outrage and gotcha Glee that
the Democratic Party live up to its me
to commitments and believe Tara Reid as
I've written repeatedly I think Biden's
a weak candidate and I wouldn't be
unhappy if the Democratic Party were
forced by some last-minute emergency to
replace him maybe with one of the
Democratic governors who has shined in
response to the coronavirus crisis but
absent other allegations that's not
going to happen
Reid seems almost engineered in a lab
to inspire skepticism in mainstream
Democrats both because her story keeps
changing and because of her bizarre
public worship of Vladimir Putin and
then she goes on to other political
issues if the story changing were enough
to get Democrats to drop uncredible
allegations they never would have even
talked to Christine Balazs he Ford on
television they never would have put her
in the newspaper they certainly wouldn't
have put her up there at the Supreme
Court confirmation hearing christine
Blasi ford is some strange person i'll
put it that way i don't want to be too
mean to Christine Blasi Ford she was a
strange character in American history
sort of came out of nowhere came out
with this crazy accusation against Brett
Kavanaugh had no evidence of it even her
best friend couldn't back it up couldn't
remember any of the details kept
changing her story and yet the
mainstream media believed her and she
kind of went away that's fine now she's
gone this person Terry who's accusing
Joe Biden was a Joe Biden staffer had a
direct relationship to Joe Biden much
much more credible but unfortunately the
mainstream media are just gonna keep
pushing that we should not let them get
away with it you know we're now seeing
obviously this backlash the New York
Times trying to move on the mainstream
media trying to move on they're just
trying to get into the 2020 election
trying to move past even their own
hypocrisy the last few years there's a
little glimmer of hope here Mike Pence
it just announced that the FDA is going
to approve antibodies tests for
coronavirus within a matter of days this
offers us a little hope on setting the
record straight because you know you've
see it in the New York Times they're
gonna rewrite history any chance they
get we can now set the record straight
at least on this big issue this world
historic event of coronavirus you need
to get the antibodies test if you think
you may have had a corona virus okay
there are big political incentives right
now to inflate the numbers to rewrite
the history of this whole episode the
numbers are already inflated the only
way that we are going to get anything
close to accurate numbers is if people
who think they've had the virus take the
antibodies test pence knows this the
Trump administration knows this that's
why they're saying we could get as many
as twenty million of them per month
because the more people who take that
test the higher the infection rate we
can see if the infection rate is much
higher than we thought it was then the
whole rationale for the shutdown goes
away the point of the shutdown was to
slow the spread if the shutdown didn't
really slow the spread if everyone got
infected anyway shows us maybe we didn't
need this global shutdown also it brings
the death count or the death rate rather
way way way down right if the number of
people infected increases dramatically
but the same number of people died then
the death rate goes way way down it's a
way to shine a little bit of clarity and
it's very important you know I hate to
say I told you so well it's very
important for us at least in the near
future to remind people that we told
them so so that the alarmists the the
rewriters of history the revisionists
and the political hacks don't get away
with with changing their tune on a world
historic episode that's going to have a
lot of implications for our politics
going forward all right got a lot more
to get to we'll do it tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
fenders hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there